اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من عمان لواء الدويري عوده
الفيف الى الواجهه في هذا الوقت في ظل
يعني وجود توترات في الجهه الاخرى ما الذي
يعني
اولا اوكرانيا
630 الف كيلو متر مربع هي مسرح عمليات
وبالتالي من اقصى الجنوب الى اقصى الشرق
الى الشمال الى الغرب وهذه هي مشروع
عمليات وبالتالي سيتم انتقاء الاهداف بناء
على معطيات استخباريه معينه لكن كل منطقه
لها خصوصيه هذه المنطقه
تعتبر الرئه التي تتنفس منها اوكرانيا من
حيث امدادات السلاح موقع استراتيجي مميز
70 كم عن الحدود اهميه اقتصاديه ثقافيه
بغض النظر عن ذلك لكن يوجد فيها قاعده
يافوريف وهذه القاعده هي كانت مكان تدريب
ولا يزال وان قلت اهميتها لالفيله الدولي
الذي تم الحديث عنه في بدايه الحرب يوجد
فيها قاعده جويه
شبكه مواصلات وعوده مواصلات سكك حديديه
اذا دعيني اقول هي التي تتنفس منها القوات
الاوكرانيه نعم يوجد مسارات مختلفه يوجد
طرق متعدده من دول مختلفه لكن هذا هو
المعبر الرئيسي للوصول الامدادات وتعتبر
منطقه لتكديس مستودعات الذخائر وحدث اكثر
من ضربه جويه على مناطق عسكريه او نقاط
اذا كانت بهذه الاهميه لماذا بقيت يعني
تبقى هادئه مقارنه مع مناطق اخرى
ولا تستهدف بما انها يعني مصدر مهم
للامدادات للقوات الاوكرانيه
لانه هناك لا اقول خطوط حمراء ولكن هناك
بعض
الاعتبارات التي لابد من اخذها بعين
الاعتبار اذا عدنا الى نهايه الحرب هي
كانت تقريبا نقطه لتجمع النازحين ووصل الى
حوالي 200,000 نقلت اليها السفارات معظم
السفرات في اثناء الهجوم على كيف تحركت
ضربا باتجاه لفين وبالتالي احتماليه الخطا
في اي صاروخ او اسقاط اي صاروخ وتناثر
الشظايا ووقوعها على سفاره على على سبيل
المثال لاي دوله هناك ستوجه اتهامات سارقه
وسيكون هناك ردود فعل وان كانت تعرف فقط
على السعيد السياسي اذا هناك محاذير معينه
لكن كلما تم تحديد اهداف ذات قيمه
استراتيجيه لابد من وجهه نظر عسكريه ان
يتم اخذها بعين الاعتبار ومهاجمه
لفرض اراده عسكريه معينه شكرا لك فايز
دويري اللواء الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من عمان